نحييكم من جديد توالت في الايام القليله
الماضيه تقارير تتحدث عن زعيم القاعده
الجديد سيف العدل وانباع عن تواجده في
ايران البدايه كانت بتقرير الامم المتحده
ترجح بان الراي السيد السائد يشير الى
انتقال قياده تنظيم القاعده الى سيف العدل
الذي كان مسؤولا عن تامين اسامه بن لادن
وقام بتدريب بعض المتورطين في هجمات
الحادي عشر مثل سبتمبر عام 2001 وذكرت
لجنه خبراء في تقرير لمجلس الامن الدولي
ان التنظيم لم يعلن خلافه سيف العدلي ايمن
الظواهري الذي قتل في غاره امريكيه
بيكابول في اغسطس العمل الماضي الخارجيه
الامريكيه بدورها سارعت الى تاييد التقرير
الاممي مؤكده بانها تؤيد ما ورد فيه
والقائل بان سيف العدل موجود فعليا في
ايران محقق سابق في مكافحه الارهاب بمكتب
التحقيقات الفيدراليه الامريكي قال
ان سيف العدل يقيم في ايران منذ سنوات
2003 حيث وضع في البدايه رهن الاقامه
الجبريه لكنه اصبح فيما بعد حرا بما يكفي
للقيام برحلات الى باكستان اما ايران فنفت
على لسان وزير خارجيتها حسين امير عبد
اللهيان وجود زعيم تنظيم القاعده سيف
العدل على اراضيها
من هو سيف العدل زعيم القاعده الجديد اسمه
الحقيقي محمد صلاح الدين زيدان ولد
بمحافظه المنوفيه شمال القاهره عام 1960
سافر لافغانستان عام
كما توجه الى السودان عام
1992 مع مؤسس التنظيم اسامه بن لادن شغل
منصب رئيس اللجنه الامنيه للقاعده في
منتصف التسعينات
منحه اسامه بن لادن عضويه مجلس شورى
التنظيم ثم تولى مسؤوليه البنيه العسكريه
للقاعده
اقام معسكرات تدريب في السودان وباكستان
وافغانستان
بعد القصف الامريكي لافغانستان عام 2001
فر الى ايران وما زال يرجح وجوده فيها حتى
الان
نناقش هذا الموضوع ونحاول فهمه في الواقع
مع ضيوفنا من الرياض هدى صالح مقدمه ومعده
برنامج جماعات على العربيه زميلتنا هدى
اهلا بك ومعنا من القاهره منير اديب
الباحث في شؤون الجماعات المسلحه اهلا
بكما ضيفاي اسمح لي ان ابدا مع زميلتي هدى
عن سيف العدل واسمه الحقيقي محمد صلاح
الدين زيدان البعض يقول بانه سيخلف
الظواهري وبانه في ايران هي ترجيح او هو
ترجيح او تاكيد بحسب متابعتك للموضوع
قراءه مختلفه شوي عن ما يدور كثير في من
خلال سواء المؤسسات ومراكز البحثيه
الغربيه او ما تتناقل وسائل الاعلام
العربيه بالنسبه لسيف العدل هو قد يكون هو
او الارجح انه هو الزعيم العسكري لتنظيم
القاعده هو في الاول كان رئيس اللجنه
الامنيه احنا نعرف للقاعده له هيكليه
عندنا الامير بعدين المجلس القياده العامه
اللي هو في اعضاء مجلس الشورى من اقصى اقل
عدد يكون سبعه واقصى عدد يكون عشره
تندرج تحتها لجان منها اللجنه الامنيه سيف
العدل كان يتولى زعامه اللجنه الامنيه على
الارجح انه هو اليوم اصبح رئيس يعني احد
اعضاء
المجلس القياده العامه رئيس
القطاع العسكري في تنظيم القاعده لكن ان
يكون امير تنظيم القاعده وجهه نظ ري
الشخصيه هذا هذا صعب رغم انه سؤال حضرتك
هنا استاذ منير رغم انه هذا الموضوع تحدثت
فيه الامم المتحده واكده فيما بعد المتحدث
باسم الخارجيات الامريكيه هو قال اولا
بانه هناك ترجيح امريكي بان سيف العدل
سيخلف الظواهري ولكنه قدم تصريح اخر ملفت
بانه في ايران
وهنا تحدث عن شبه التاكيد ما رايك
اهلا وسهلا بك يا استاذه
وبضيفتك الكريمه وبكل مشاهدي العربيه يعني
لعل بعد مقتل ايمن الظواهري في يوليو من
العام 2022
ذهبت ترجيحات كثيره على ان السلطه او
الدعامه ربما تنتقل الى سيف العدل
وبالتالي ما ادعته الخارجيه الامريكيه لم
يكن جديدا ولكن هذه الترجيحات ربما بنيت
على
قواعد قد يكون منها كما ذكرت الاستاذه هدى
انه المسؤول مسؤول اللجنه الامنيه وانه
كان احد الحراس الشخصيين لاسامه بن لادن
وانه قد يكون الشخص الوحيد قد يكون في
حقيقه الامر من الجيل المؤسس وبالتالي
تذهب هذه الترجيحات الى ان هذه الدعامه قد
تذهب الى سيف العدل عدم وجود اخرين
من الجيل القديم للقاعده فضلا على ان هناك
سؤال كبير ومهم دائما يطرح واعتقد انك سوف
تطرحينه الان لماذا لم يعلن التنظيم تولي
زعيمه الجديد يعني هذا امر في غايه
الاهميه لعل وجود سيف العدل في ايران هو
السبب الحقيقي بعدم الاعلان حتى هذه
اللحظه
كذلك الموضوع المرتبط بافغانستان وطالبان
التي تنكر الى اليوم وفاه الظواهري محرج
كذلك الموضوع هذه نقطه جد مهمه ولكني كنت
ساجلها لحلقات اخرى الوقت يدركنا وددت
سؤال عن عدم حديث ايران كذلك ايران لطالما
تكتمت عن وجود القيادات استاذه هدى للمره
الالف ربما الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
تحرش ايران وتتحدث عن ايواءها لقيادات
تتبع تنظيمات ارهابيه
ما المتوقع من الردود الايرانيه وكيف نفسر
هذه النقطه هو طبعا الشيء الجديد هو ان
لاول مره الولايات المتحده تاتي وتوجه
اصبع الاتهام بان قياده مهمه جدا وخطيره
جدا ومسؤوله عن عدد من التفجيرات الخارجيه
اللي ارتكبها تنظيم القاعده هي موجوده
لديها وهذا تحذير غربي لاير ان اي عمليه
خارجيه تنفذها ينفذها تنظيم القاعده ستكون
ايراني هي المتهمه بها
فلذلك القاعده محرجه حركه طالبان محرجه
احنا نعرف طبعا اجنحه في داخل حركه طالبان
ساعدت سيف العدل ومن معها للخروج وقتها من
معاني الابورا
ويعني وان يتوجهوا الى ايران ومعهم حكمه
تيار وعلاقات قديمه مع عدد من القيادات
المهمه في حركه طالبان الجميع محرج من هذا
الكشف الامريكي هو ليس كشف يعني المعروف
جدا من قديم لازم حتى احنا ما ننسى ان
خالد شيخ محمد يعني لدى الولايات المتحده
منفذي ومهندسي تفجيرات 11 سبتمبر لدولايات
المتحده اجهزه الامنيه في عدد من الدول
العربيه والخليجيه لديها قيادات بارزه
ومهمه جدا كانت قريبه جدا من سيف العدل
والقيادات مجلس شورى القاعده فكثير من
المعلومات المتوفره عن اجهزه الامن سليمان
ابو غيث بعد ما استلمت الولايات المتحده
وهو كان ايضا مع سيف العدل ويقيم في نفس
محل الاقامه مع زوجات وابناء بن لادن ذكر
في اعترافاته او خلال محاكمته والتحقيقات
سالوه عن سيف العدل وابو محمد المصري فقال
لهم انهم نعم هم في ايران لكنهم بيتمتعوا
بالحياه الطبيعيه والعاديه وانهم تخلوا عن
الاشتراك والانضمام في تنظيم ويقال بانه
كان في اقامه يعني جبريه ولكن فيما بعد
تمكن من الذهاب والعوده لباكستان باختصار
شديد او انتهى الوقت طيب انتهى الوقت على
كل يعني دهمنا الوقت لانه اخذنا الموضوع
متاخرين شوي بسبب بعض الامور التقنيه ولكن
اكيد باننا سنعود الى النقطه التي
اقترحتها يا استاذ منير عن حرج التنظيم
وسنعود كذلك الى كل النقاط المهمه التي
اتيت عليها هدى صالح مقدمه ومعدل برامج
برنامج جماعات على العربيه من القاهره
منيره اديب الباحث في شؤون الجماعات
المسلحه شكرا لكم وبهذا نختم بانوراما
لهذا المساس السلام عليكم
[موسيقى]